I like art I like making things and
being creative it seems like a uniquely
human thing to do there's been a lot of
talk lately about robots taking our jobs
and I don't doubt that's going to happen
for most jobs I think if you sort of
extrapolate what AI and machines are
good at now - what we can make them good
at it sort of makes sense and I also
agree with the view that robots taking
our jobs is not necessarily a bad thing
because if we can have machines doing
more laborious or monotonous tasks that
frees up sort of a niche for humans to
specialize and the things that machine's
can't do like art writing being creative
which typically we protect as uniquely
human but I also wonder what happens if
you keep extrapolating what we can make
machines do what happens when we can
make AI that can write stories or make
artworks or entertain and give us
content that we consider aesthetically
beautiful what happens when AI are
better artists than humans
I guess there's two options either this
will happen when and we have to deal
with the question of what what do humans
do next what do we have left that that
we could fill or the other option is
that this is never possible that AI will
never be able to be artists I know of at
least one research group who are
currently working on how to teach AI to
write stories how do you break down the
component
of an entertaining narrative into what
can essentially be planned and I
actually think it will be possible
there's already sort of Turing tests for
poetry where there are websites where
you can see a poem that's generated back
by an AI besides a real poem and you
have to try and guess which one was
written by a human and it's actually not
that easy to work it out I think given
enough time we'll probably be able to do
the same thing with stories those
recently talking to someone about what
makes a good story whether it's a movie
or a book or anything else and our
agreement was that sort of the worst
movies we'd seen might have had all the
elements of a successful story like a
love scene a drama an emotional scene or
action but they seemed like accumulation
of all the the best scenes of other
movies there was nothing really unique
about the movie and that made it bad
what I'm saying is that I think the
worst films or movies or stories are
predictable and maybe an AI can be
taught to pick out the best scenes from
all the best things that's been learning
from but maybe an AI generated story can
only ever be predictable on the other
hand if if AI do manage to write or
become great artists what will humans do
I'm not sure I think we really protect
our artistic abilities as what makes us
unique maybe something else we protect
as sort of our identity as humans as the
ability to love so many of our artworks
and stories come down
to the overwhelming feeling of love
maybe that's all we can all we can do
that distinguishes us from AI but maybe
you can teach an AI to love as well I
don't know